wow
wow don't they look handsome you guys
you guys look incredible I know do you
have family in the military I do my
whole family is Navy everybody from my
uh my uncle to my grandfather my my
great-grandfather was a paratrooper in
World War II which is insane to me cuz
if you've ever been skydiving you know
no I haven't yeah well if you have any
level of depression at all I wouldn't
recommend so were you always funny as a
kid oh yeah I constant detention and my
mom my mom would whoop me for days for
getting detention and now that same
skill that got me detention just bought
her a house so there you go there you go
now mine was talking too much really who
would have thought gu yes and now I'm
making money off of it whatever uh so
did you know what you wanted to be did
you have an idea of what you wanted to
do when you were younger I had no idea I
was going to be in television I wasn't
going to work on TV I wanted to work in
in fact in my freshman year of college
when I took a television performance
class my department chairman told me
Roker you have a perfect face for
radio like all right well you can't hear
that enough whatever so over but you do
have a great voice actually so I've
never been crazy about my voice but oh
my gosh I sound like a valley girl you
sound like s like it's got the low end
like uh you can L me to sleep for sure
in the best well I I was going to say I
don't know if that's a it is a
compliment and here's the 5ay
forecast so wait over 17 million
followers that's a little it's
intimidating kind of overwhelming right
a tad bit it does feel like it came out
of nowhere but then I have to remind
myself as much as it feels overnight
because it did happen very fast via
social media I'd been doing comedy for
12 years before that so anytime I feel
overwhelmed about like people coming up
on the street or at restaurants or
something like that and they ask like oh
I'm so sorry to bother you I'm like
you're not a bother at all for 11 years
I begged somebody you kidding me notice
me yeah you know what worse than
everybody knowing you nobody knowing you
it's amazing this is the first special
for Netflix and I I couldn't be more
excited cuz I think again it's just
going to broaden me to a different
audience that either sees me as just a
Tik Tok comedian or someone who just
does crowd work I think they're going to
be pleasantly surprised at what else I
can do oh I love that and I love that
when people underestimate you cuz then
it's like fun and it fuels you and you
want to win them over course oh yeah
that's the best reveng success the
underdog is always a better position in
my opinion but speaking of his fans
though this happened recently at one of
match show watch this and she hased you
to figure
out orinal yo can we get a paramedic
real quick paramedic please you okay oh
she's going to cry are you all right you
feeling okay you promise we get a
picture with you yeah of course just
don't use it for the obituary my
God what
happened um well she uh she she's okay
she's fine which is why the joke is
funny oh of course of course no we
wouldn't have continued the show
happened like some going get her out of
here I got to plug merch no no no I no
this
look
C that's aming amazing this was probably
25 minutes into one of our our
headlining shows and I hear this
commotion and I look down and I I could
see she's she's convulsing so I I
immediately once I recognize what was
happening I called for anybody being a
paramedic in the room and luckily the
people at the venue and people who do
work in the medical field that were in
in the audience rushed to her side
immediately I have to leave the stage
when that happens so I can be informed
as to what's going on while she's
getting tended to properly and not in
anybody's way and it was like seven or
eight minutes later I would say my
security came back and was like hey she
she wants to stay I was like I'll give
her a refund like she doesn't have to
stay but she I went out there I was like
let me just go talk to her make sure
she's all right and I walked out and the
first thing I said I was like are you
okay she was like yeah can I have a
picture I was like yeah no
flash she had epilepsy what a wild thing
to ask first man but you go you got to
you got you got to respect the passion
you know she wanted to stay she had to
you know comedy makes people happy you
make people happy you make people laugh
I forgot this and I went to a show here
recently in New York and it made me feel
so good to get out and just laugh with
other people absolutely you have no idea
brings people together to such an
extreme level you think it's just random
jokes that you're just telling to make
people
happy through yeah absolutely she was
such a good sport about everything it's
actually happened at a show for like
shows for me like your live situations
too like where things have happened like
that and you get freak out cuz you're
like well wait cuz loud music I'm like
make it go away like all these kind of
things happen all the time we had uh we
had an overdose in Indianapolis like two
weeks ago and the audience was Furious
that he did not offer to share with the
rest to
the
mad I had no idea Indianapolis was so
ratchet like they were so
[Music]
upset like usually people rally behind
something that they're like yeah make
sure he's okay and they were like
selfish selfish oh my God you're so
funny I know it was it was so ridiculous
Matt R everybody n collection is on
netlix starting November 15th You' got
to check it
out
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home